In 1815, the eruption of Mount Tambora plunged parts of the world into darkness...
...and marked a gloomy period that came to be known as the "Year Without A Summer."
So when Mary and Percy Shelley...
...arrived at the house of Lord Byron on Lake Geneva,...
...their vacation was mostly spent indoors.
For amusement, Byron proposed a challenge to his literary companions:...
...who could write the most chilling ghost story?
This sparked an idea in 18-year-old Mary.
Over the next few months, she would craft the story of Frankenstein.
Popular depictions may evoke a green and groaning figure,...
...but that's not Mary Shelley's monster.
In fact, in the book, Frankenstein refers to the nameless monster's maker,...
...Dr. Victor Frankenstein.
So tense is the struggle between creator and creature...
...that the two have merged in our collective imagination.
Before you read or reread the original text,...
...there are several other things that are helpful to know about Frankenstein...
...and how it came to assume its multiple meanings.
The book traces Dr. Frankenstein's futile quest to impart and sustain life.
He constructs his monster part by part from dead matter...
...and electrifies it into conscious being.
Upon completing the experiment,...
...however, he's horrified at the result and flees.
But time and space aren't enough to banish the abandoned monster,...
...and the plot turns on a chilling chase between the two.